>> SAY,
WHAT METCS MAKE
THAT DE?
>> THE RTHAT'S MYME DOI CAN LISA
IT'S THE I'VE
EVER TO MAKE.
>>AN BRING
KACOLLINS.
ITRUD SPECIFICA ABOTHEORETICAL ?
THE PRESIDENTSE YES,E WANT.
GOING TO MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON HIS HEALTH
ADVISERS THERE THAT WERE IN THE
ROOM WITH DR. BIRX AND  THAT HEE
TO OPE'S SAFE TO DOSO.
BUT KE PRENT
DEALING WITH TWO DRE
FAOT
REALLY GIVING ANY INDICATION OF
ATETRICSY
GOTOHA SI PE C TE, HOW MANY
TESTS ARE BEING ADMINISTERED A
WE,RATE IS IN
EAEAUST BASICLYD GOING TO HEIN
THE ULTIMATE DECISION HERE. KNOS
THERE ARE MANY DISCUSSIONS UNDER
WAY INSIDE THEHT
E
REO TS. ECONOMY STARTING NEXT
JAKE, EVEN
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT MAY.
THE PRESEN ANNOUNCINATND TASK F.
THAT'SHEORCE T REOPENING THE
ECONOMY.SOINLY IATDENT ISJAKE, S
IS H HESITANT T
IN THE ROOM WEREOALK ABOUT
REOPENING THE ECONO NEXT YOU AN.
BOTH GET  SAID WE
ARE NOT SEEINGHE YET
THE UNITED AN
HAT NTIMES" RNGHOSEONOW AND
THOSEAL DISTANCING GUIDELINES E
LET UP AFTER 30YS WHAT YOU'RE GR
SOORE WE THATIFFERENCEISERS
THE P THE COUNTRY
HIS WHOIS TIME TO
DO SO YET.
>> KAITLANTRUUT HOW SOME OF HNDD
OR NOT THEY
AND THE PRESIDENT REFUSGANSWER
WIATIONS COMINGM THERIGHT.
>> Reporter: YEAH, HE OFFERED NT
BEEN LEA
AND ADVISING HIMN HE ONLYOMUT HT
OP CITING PEOPLE LIKE DR.
FAUCI AND DR. RX EVENSEE, WHEN
WAS ANSWERING QUESTIONS ABOUT D
PRESIDENT IS THEN BEING
WITH. KAITL S
MUCH.G MEOW IS ADMININER
DR. SCOTTHO HASNDING VOI THE
JANUARNG THE  EARLY GOTTLIEB, TS
SI  HAV GO T
HOWTE TO BEE IT'S  TING BACK TO
TESTINGN THAT'
IN TERMS OF WHERE YOU WANT STAR
TO CLOSED SPAC
PEOPLE TOORTLY THE REALITHE REA.
FU WILL BE A
BA AS HEAD INTO
JULYAUHAT'SUS.
BUT T IS WE'LL BE
RETURNING TO WORK BACITYNRMS
OF
IN TERMS OF TH NUMBER OFOU WAN
PERFORM, AS WE OUT OFHI
PANDEM THERE WILL STILL BE
CASES
YOU WANT TO HAVE E ITH THE ARUNP
BLY 7MI
THERE ARE  ENCOUNTERS
WITH THE PRIMARY CARE SYSTEM
EVERY WEEK.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO TEST THAT
LEVELPEOPLE, YOUIGHT WANT
TO TESTS O 3.
PEOP EWEEK,EOO THEEALTH BIUS
TOET SE STILL ALL.
>> WHY DO YOU SAY SUMWILL BE A ?
I THOUTDAIONAL
SCIENCES WAS THAT THIS SUMMERSN
WARM AIRSNCT
AN
>> WE DOKN FOR SURE.
NA
CIRCULATE HE.
IS IS NOVEL IT'S LIKELY
TO TRANSFER INTO THESUMM
BUTPLET TRANSMISSION BECOMES
LESS EFFICIENT IN THE HOT HUMID
MONTHS.
ALSO EPIDEMIOLOGYCHAN B ARE
OUTSIDSO DO GET
V ISUMMER.
TYPICALLY WHAPR
SUMMERTIME ANTERIC
AND IK THAT ARE RESPIRATORYS.
BUT WE DON'T KN WHETH WILL A
IT'S THEOR
THE SOUTHERN H CORONAVIRUS YET.E
T OF  I ISIDENT TRUMP LISTENINGO
YOUR IDEAS?
>> I'VE CERTAINLY MADE TBLE TO E
PUT FORW WAS YAN SEE
SUCTION IN N
YOU WANT W
ADDITIONAL TWO WEEKS YOUSEE A SI
WE SHOULD START SEEING ANED RED
THE SECOND HALF OFTOWARD T APRI.
IF Y THE TIMINT WEINE, THAT WOUK
TO WORK. OTHER THING WE SAY IS
COMMUNITY.
RIGHT NOW SCREENING ISCONFINED .
WE DO NEED TO CONTA ORP
SCREENING.
WE'LL BE TAKIN STEP T
REOPINCOBEFORE WE HAVE THE OPTI
TAKE
TAKING THAT
IT'S NOT WORTH WAITINGE HENG OHF
SCREENGTHERE?
>>LOOI-IT'S A CAREFUL BALANCING.
AS A PLICIAL,LIKE TO HAVE OPTAL
CAPACITY.WOD
CAUTION.
WELSO NEED QUITEFRANKLY, T A HEH
ICATIONS TO WHATREHE LONGER WE .
E' LOT OF MORDI
RTEWITH MILD STRO ,SNDAS WE'VE
IT'S A CAREFUL ING.
I O SREENINACE, ESPECIALLY
FOR THE FALL.
TH ACONCER
WORRIED ABOUT B
ALSO NEEDO WORRY ABOUT AT
AND HAT WE NEEDAS W TO SOO
RESIDENTIA TT
HAVE MUCH
SCREENING, HOPEFULLY ONE
EFFECTIVE THEO DEAL
EMLL AF IN THE THAT THEL
BE A OUTBREAKS AND EVEN
THE RNOTHER EPIDEMIC.
>>N YOU'R TALKING ABOUT ARE Y TE
CORONAVIRUSES ARE
THERERE
MI
ABO THE TESTS?
WHAT EXACTLY KIND OF SNGS
ARYOABOUT?>>'M TESTSHATCTION.
THENTIBODY TES USEFUL BLIC HEAL
MENTAT A COMMUNITY WHERE VE BNO
THE CORONAVIRUS.
WHEN THOSESCALOGY TESTS POPULATD
DEVELOPED  WPERCENGE THE TOTAL.
POCKETS COULD BEER,SHER, BE
EREN  WOER WCHECKOUT
LINES ATSTORES, PEOPLE TOUCH A
YOU'INEL OFSURE PROBABLY ABO
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE VERYHIGH.T
WORK SAFELY.R SMALL%